magali est en colère qu'elle est le
premier mot qui vous est venu à l'esprit
quand vous avez vu le le clip j'ai dit
la [ __ ]
on va la refaire
c'est parce qu'en fait quand elle
regarder le clip c'est quoi c'est le
droit dans une porte et oh là là mais là
on peut pas non mais non alors on parle
pas bien sûr on parle du clip c'est
d'être la qualité du clip il le craint
le grade de l'image libéraux même est
très bien de quoi le clip en lui même
est très bien doté juste qu'est ce qu'il
fout là dedans quoi que ce soit il à
doublure ou pas la doublure qu'est ce
qu'elle fout là dedans pro vous en
voulez à martial approuvait la juge elle
a fait quoi elle a fait quoi et qui
attendait depuis le mois de juin de
mairie depuis le mont et février
oui on entend parler malheureusement de
l' affaire d'héritage
mais laëtitia sont dit oui le truc c'est
qu'à un moment donné faut quand même se
rendre compte qu'elle avait énormément
fait de mal à david et alors a
énormément fait de mal en empêchant
david on a encore vu il ya quelques
jours durant son interview de voir son
père il a poireauté toute la journée à
marnes-la-coquette sans avoir la
possibilité de voir son père je sais pas
quelle mère digne de ce nom peut
empêcher n'importe quel enfant on est
toutes plus ou moins deux mamans
d'empêcher un enfant d'un morceau de
terre alors est-ce que vous l'aimiez
avons non vous la verrez donc comprend
des noms n'ont jamais pu engager ou quoi
mais non cadrée non elle a ce truc
d'être toujours là à côté de lui et
prenant les photos ma chaîne je suis la
meilleure jusqu'à plus belle avec sa
voix de michel jacquet marrant je peux
tout simplement pas
depuis 2009 quand johnny a eu ce souci
de santé la vie voilà sur certains
sujets histoire pourquoi elle fume
bordel pas possible elle empêche les
lausannois repères en fait sa faune m
mais donc vous croyez tout ce qui est
dit non je crois pas je crois pas je
vois les yeux de david quand ils parient
même pas mettre ça sur moi je sais pas
mais elle est là et même pas dans son
interview à tf1 où je sais qu'elle est
passée à côté des claques au sénat
mais je connais pas personnellement mais
peut-être très sympa ce coup l'aï déjà
rencontré non ils vont même pas ah oui
mais vous l'aimez pas du tout notre
temps vous appris votre johnny c'est ça
pour moi johnny c'est mon père spirituel
ouais il a toujours été là depuis tout
petit justement livre m6 s'il aime
johnny vous devriez l'aimais aussi parce
qu'ils n'ont pas supporté qu'une en a
failli mal aux enfants de johnny et
encore plus à joy vous êtes en train de
me faire comprendre que johnny n'a
favorisé le il a accordé le l'héritage
des héritages magic trackpad est ce que
vous avez acheté leurs gongs gouasmi
gelé à chaque coup à l'heure je n'ai
acheté parce que je me suis dit que même
si l'argent revienne à boudou excusez
moi je pourrais je pourrais pas dire est
que j'ai vu tous les fans est voilà et
boudou sur les réseaux software pas dire
laetitia non non moi j'appelle et en
plus moi moi je pose moi c'est la belle
comme ça mais on va l'appeler madame
boudouyssou périgueux non c'est pas mal
l'idée finale elle était mariée
oui oui non mais je comprends votre
colère que je respecte bien sûr mais non
il faut quand même respecter les gens
d'abord parce que tout simplement vous
c'est vrai niveau de l'abattoir
l'histoire les douloureuses pour tout le
monde de toute façon ça il faut jamais
l'oublier tout le monde souffre dans
cette histoire et tout le monde se bat
en revanche je tiens à signaler que ce
que je vous ai dit hier par rapport que
c'est bien laetitia qui a dicté le mot à
jada l'idée ce mot invraisemblable très
lyrique comme ça faire laetitia ça m'a
été confirmée aujourd'hui par une amie
très proche de l'été assure que je ne
vois pas les richesses et quand tu
donnes une info une bonne que je dit et
janry touati d'oyonnax fois les vannes
jean michel mr dray va très bien les
drôles d'amis à laëtitia excuse moi tu
abandonnes unis de la voix de jeanne est
il de la voile est ici à richard vers
l'inde et drôles d'amis qui te balance
des infos comme ça excuse moi mais faire
ses vrais arrêtez de vous en prendre à
lui donne une enfant il ya au moins là
il avait annoncé dans quelques longs il
est depuis le début je dis qu'il est
pour le roi david et alors il ravi de
david mais alors me donner leurs frais
vas-y fais ce que tu as à dire alors
qu'est ce que voulait dire alors ben je
voulais seulement répond à mademoiselle
qui est charmante au demeurant quand
qu'est ce qu'elle fout dans le clip elle
a seulement été seulement 27 ans
l'épousé de johnny bien sûr voilà
pourquoi les enfants étaient vérité
parce que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est johnny qui a signé un héritage et
2 vous ne connaissez pas vous ne la
connaissez pas vous aideront à les
tester
mais à partie quand vous la connaissez
pas quel beau changeriez d'avis si vous
la rencontre signé voilà faut pas non
plus jugé les gens comme ça il l'insulté
sans l'avoir connu vous avez ce cas les
gens qui l'ont rencontré jean tout ce qu
elle est très sympathique
non mais c'est vrai on a fait ce qu'on
dit même vous mais moi j'ai jamais
insulté laetitia alors qu'elle ne
devrait pas y a